والله احنا بنتمنى من اخواننا المصريين
وشقاء انه يعني يدخلوا مي يدخلوا مساعدات
والدوي اقسم بالله الدكاتره مه لقين شيء
دوفي صاروا الملح الملح صارت كيلت حوالي ب
50 شيكل يعني انت متخيل انحط على جروح
الناس ش اسمه ملع عشان يطهروها يعني وصلنا
لمرحله حرجه جدا الناس تموت قاعد ملقين
دواء والترشيح والوجع هذا كله الامراض دب
البلد يعني ما في شيء الواحد قادر يقدمه
غير ان نتمنى من الله ثم من المصريه
اخواننا يفتحوا لنا يعني يدخلوا لنا
مساعدات ويتهاون معان كذا ميه كهرباء فش
كهرباء الكهرباء لنا الحين اكثر من 100
يوم وهي مقطوعه والدنيا كلها نشاف على
الاخر يعني وكل بين عربي وعربي صار ايش
بين الدول صار جدران فاحنا نتمنى من الله
ان الجدران هذه تزول والعرب يكونوا ايد
وحده وترجع يعني نرجع زي زمان قبل الجدران
هذو م ياجن ونكون على قلب رج واحد يا
رجل